welcome to the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences and our annual
celebration of the nominated live-action
and animated short films I'm John bloom
chair of the short films and feature
animation branch and one of its three
governors with Bill kroyer and Bob
Rogers this the kickoff event of Oscar
week is always sold out and filled up
for 12 years now it's been my honor to
welcome you to this event and I've saved
all those speeches that now read like a
history a history of my hopes and dreams
for what the Oscar shorts could be that
their quality should be shared with a
larger audience and the import and
validity of these categories would be
recognized I couldn't be prouder to tell
you these goals have been well achieved
this event started as only an annual
public screening of the nominated shorts
in the spring is now consistently sold
out and tremendously in demand it was at
the time nearly the only way Academy
members could see our shorts eleven
years ago it was moved to before the
academy award ceremony allowing our
filmmaker nominees to participate and
its popularity soared now partnered with
shorts HD for the last ten years the
collection has enjoyed exceptional
distribution success with notably the
worldwide theatrical release of all
three categories continuing to grow with
impressive box office for an indie
limited release gross ticket sales so
far this year are running nice nicely
ahead of last year's rep
two million three hundred and fifty
thousand dollar tally in more than four
hundred theaters additional distribution
avenues from cable pay-per-view
streaming services and iTunes begin
today and increase access greatly pay
cable availability alone will reach into
80 million cable homes we project over a
half million viewers total will pay to
see the shorts this year in all are many
release release mediums and given this
broad release strong reviews are pouring
into just a brief sampling they are
among the finest movies I've seen this
year of any length said the Washington
Post better than most of the
feature-length films up for Best Picture
that one is from awards daily I could
have written it myself and the New York
Times these shorts offer a vision of
what the Academy Awards could and should
be but rarely are eclectic cosmopolitan
scrappy and surprising
now that Academy members are provided
dvds of all the shorts in addition to
the nominee to the nominee screenings
voter participation has skyrocketed as
has member appreciation of these shorts
and so my halls directed some of Patty
Duke but best known for his starring
film roles in The Lord of the Rings
trilogy in Rudy in his debut as a child
actor in Goonies to name but a few we
are very honored to have as our host and
I'm very excited to introduce the man
we'll take it from here the super
accomplished Sean Astin all right all
right all right thank you thank you for
that
it's been almost 20 years and I thought
it was appropriate for me to bring in
this certificate of nomination for award
to share with you show you that it has
remained an important place in our home
and that it was an honor just to be
nominated I remember with my first short
film was called on my honor and it was
made on 35 millimeter film and you can
explain to your grandkids later what
that means then we had gone through the
Academy Award nomination process and it
was getting down to the wire and we knew
the next morning was the announcements
were coming and so my friend Milton
justice and I my producer we drove up I
don't know if it's Beachwood or whatever
Franklin whatever it is where you can
get up real close to the hollywood sign
and we had it wasn't a seance but I
distinctly recall looking at the sign
and then looking out over the sweep of
Los Angeles and promising to use an
Academy Award nomination for good it was
not to be that year uh then we did my
wife Christine and I've Christine's not
here but she she stands here with me
because she's with two of our kids but
we were nominated together she produced
we produced a kangaroo court and we were
at we were a Los Angeles Valley College
together sometime between when we
finished the film and I had done Rudy
and we wanted to go to college so we
were getting our general ed credits and
and and we got a call in the morning
from the writer saying you did it you
did it like we did what we did what like
you got nominated for an Oscar we're
like oh man whoa I have to go to spanish
101 right now sitting in mr. Rodriguez
this class like I don't I don't have to
be here I'm gonna Kadim e Award nominee
and that year there was at the big
ceremony at the shrine I think it was
that year we
there Tim Tim Tim Tim Tim Tim Tim help
me with Tim close to the moon no duh to
infinity right ok Tim Allen I'm just
kidding Tim it's the animators here's an
animation joke ok so um so Tim Allen
announced our category and and he opened
up the envelope when he went no it's a
tie listen to the pin drop their people
that's how we felt and and I remember we
went to the Academy screening we watched
it and the art movie might have been
first or second and very proud watching
our film in this room on this
extraordinary screen with this quality
productions just projections you're
about to see it if you haven't before
it's incredible and then a movie called
Trevor came on and Trevor just I voted
for Trevor it was about this young boy
in his coming of age and his identity
and his sexuality and it was just a
really really beautiful thing but anyhow
they said it's a tie and I looked at my
wife as if to say like we got it because
Trevor's was the best and then maybe we
were the second-best it out and and and
then and then it's a wonderful life
Franz Kafka's it's a wonderful life one
a brilliant movie short film and and so
I leaned forward to jobeth williams who
was is an actress and had her short film
nominated that year and i said i bet we
were third anyhow it's all fun and games
when it comes to the oscar award race
thing but but my i have the heart of a
short film maker I think in short films
everything that happens in the day if
I'm in my car no matter what I'm doing I
feature films are amazing but man it
takes a lot short film you can just wrap
it up and you're in your heart in your
soul and you can just feel it and love
it and live it and you know the fact
that it takes some people three or five
years to get there
two minute short film made is a
spectacular thing of human expression so
anyhow I will just say that is my job to
be brief so let me just skip through all
that we have an exciting program it's a
very simple format for the evening for
those of you who don't know we're going
to screen the animated short films and
was that a surprise yeah so we have I
think five one two three four five
animated films i've seen them they're
beautiful we then get invite the
filmmakers on to the stage have a little
a quick discussion because there's
there's not a lot of time but we'll have
a little chance to pick the brains of
the filmmakers and then we'll have a
break and when we come back from the
break there will be will screen the
live-action films there are five and
I've seen them as well they're
emotionally run the gamut so prepare
yourselves for that and then afterwards
we will have a conversation with the
short film makers of the live action
short subjects so without further ado
thank you very much Academy for letting
me come and be here I feel as though I'm
among my people
what was just set on the stage here
today about short films being made
public for the world and all of its
glory I just am so excited for that and
so proud of that and now you get
something really special enjoy this
beautiful screening of these animated
short films nominated this year tell her
now all right all right some penalty
dramatic it'll all get done whoa hello
TT and I got you a cream slice oh you
are a good boy I want you two to get on
steam coming from me
our apartment is nice too but my parents
are modernist architects and that causes
problems our dining room chairs have
almost three when my friends come over
to play they look around and say you
live here yes I live here with my
parents two sisters and my grandmother
come of it my grandmother tells us that
no other siblings in the whole world
quarrels and pays us on friday if we
don't quarrel june the week this is our
reward for being more like other kids
which is what we want also ever dealt a
big debt not talk to you p.m. she also
tells us we have to fold our clothes
neatly when we go to bed at night so if
there's a fire we can get dressed in a
hurry otherwise we'll have to run out
naked imagine that
a single line is what you get it when
you should get it right this one I'm
saying hello everyone it may we would
love to invite the animated film makers
or under the stage please Daisy Jacobs
Christopher heaves he's sorry Robert
condo dice tu to me Patrick Osborne
y'all coming did they leave they watch a
feast and went out to get food that's
what happened that was so much fun I
don't it was and heartbreaking and
warming and sort of maddening I was a
lot of things it's hard for me sitting
there I have two kinds of questions I
want to ask everybody I want to ask
story questions and I want to ask
process questions so I think what I'll
do is ask sort of openness questions and
you can take it where you i'm sure
you've been talking a lot about your
films and will continue to so first of
all congratulations yeah
alright so first we have the bigger
picture Daisy and it's Christopher here
too yeah Daisy Christopher okay so for
me getting vacuumed up vacuuming up that
room laughed out loud and felt kind of
uneasy and terrified at the same time
not being sure whether I'd be a vacuum
or vacuum II am I in my life but between
between that moment the whimsy of that
moment in the look of it and then the
and then being in a room alone with his
with his mother after she's died a
heartbreaking moment to me though you
know it's a pretty powerful short film
that can accomplish both of those moods
what um yeah what can you say what can
you say to help us with that with that I
understand why you did that well I
actually animated the both those scenes
very differently so the hoovering up
scene and the characters are life-size
so they're little bit bigger than I am
painted onto the wall with extendable
arms and so we had lots of people sort
of helping on that one and I was jumping
around getting everything into the
Hoover but for the where he cleans up
his mother I did that on my own and I
shut all the doors and I did it in the
corner of the set very quietly and so I
did them in different ways different
aspects in the beginning in them in the
kitchen they closed the cupboard what it
doesn't repeat really does it that
particular kind of thing where he
becomes sort of part of the cupboard
what was the impulse there I think
that's very interesting that you've
mentioned that because it doesn't repeat
i think i just wanted to do that it's
your movie you get to do it as awesome
that's awesome and christopher what how
did you how did you help with this so I
/ produced the film so am i guess like
Daisy this very personal story today Z
and then she'd kind of come up with this
incredibly innovative technique and I
think what I loved about it is the fact
that the emotions of the characters
really come through through the
animation
and I think that's kind of incredible
for audiences to kind of enjoy that and
I mean it was just I guess it was just
about being able to get because it's
life size we have to have a huge studio
for about six months to be able to make
this film and then it was just about
bringing the creatives into to kind of
really give the story the power it
deserved it's intimate to me it could be
it could be either could be a massive
studio you could be doing it all in your
I have no way of I have no way of
knowing how you did it but it's a what a
beautiful collaboration all right let me
go to the dam keeper and I want to know
can I have a fox I think Fox is arguably
the greatest protagonist of a movie in
the history of film I mean forever I
mean Fox is just flawless really that
moment when the when the bathroom door
opens and Fox has that horrified look on
his her face tell me about that moment
tell me about achieving that moment just
that look okay well that's he your dice
yeah yes okay dice to sue me go well you
know we really wanted to make sure that
at the moment is something anyone can
relate to whether you're fox or the pig
or someone looking at the site of
bullying you know from outside and and
you know Fox's facial expression as well
as you know pigs embarrassment like he
didn't want Fox to see him in that you
know condition so that was something we
really focused on did trying to achieve
that sort of authenticity as much as we
could tell you about the moral you know
you're with pig if you've got a heart or
a soul you're with pig through this
whole story and so happy when the
laughter comes and all of that and then
and then he you know he's wrong he's
hurt at least he thinks he's been hurt
he doesn't he's operating on not enough
information with the whole picture but
then he chooses to destroy the entire
town does he know what's going to happen
what is the moral moment there yeah
you know we really thought of it as not
so much a conscious choice to destroy
everything as it was a choice to neglect
his responsibility and I don't think I
think the consequences I think at that
point he's numb to the consequences and
I think caught in his own world I think
seeing the world just from his point of
view and and you know really this film
was about a character like him it wasn't
about changing the world it was really
about him changing the way he saw the
world and so that was something that we
always had as part of our film that we
just wanted our character despite all
the hardships to be able to have the
strength to just change the way he sees
things because the town is not going to
change for him hmm I have three
daughters and so I you know going
through their their schooling and
everything art and drawing is just a
part of everything but a lot of times
it's the you know the kids are left to
fend for themselves and this story with
Fox is about saying well no drawing
isn't just a wonderful way to reflect
what you see but there can be real
social commentary it can you say
anything about that I mean meaning that
Fox you know [ __ ] the boy is upset you
know and and or the pig is upset and Fox
sort of goes like hey you could look at
the world a little differently you know
let's let's flip this on a tendon and
drawing is them is the medium is the the
absolutely Thor's hammer I mean
obviously you know we're both artists
and you know we always talked about like
Pig Fox is who we want to be so using
art to sort of free ourselves but really
we are pig you know we are sort of
introverted if we can't quite explain
valves you know as freely as we want to
and we learned as we grew up we learn
how to become like Fox but truly we are
pig and in a way the drawing was a part
of you know what we learned to sort of
free ourselves to express ourselves that
makes sense well it's beautiful alright
I have three doll
good mostly I was really hungry watching
this short film I've really helps making
it well did you tell me it tell me about
okay so everybody's got pets I'm sure
anybody who's a filmmaker anybody who's
got the stop motion thing on their
iPhone now we all we all have a story
about our about our about our pet or
animal and and I just want to hear for a
minute like how do you get this story
told like when you see it I mean the
lusciousness of all the food and the
sweetness of the of the what is it basil
well you know the it's it's so alive but
at the moment that you're starting to
make it that you're because its
operating in a bigger studio environment
how how do you how do you set yourself
apart how do you set this idea apart
from others it actually started with the
idea of maybe being able to tell the
story of relationship through dinners
dinners like a ritual that everyone
understands that we all take part in and
I thought well when you're single and
alone you eat by yourself on the couch
and it looks a certain way and if you
cut straight to a first date maybe where
you're trying a little hard and it looks
very particular and put together and
then another relationship that's
comfortable eating looks a certain way
and all on into you know having a family
and what that looks like in the kind of
sort of explosion of fun that that could
be and so I had recorded all my dinners
in 2012 like one second of every dinner
for every day and beginning of each meal
I get halfway through its in different
parts sometimes and sometimes is not
sometimes we didn't eat we just had
drinks since just cheers but and there
was something kind of magical what
putting all that all that together and I
thought you know after a while the idea
of maybe having a puppy underneath the
table in the negative space growing up
what kind of connected on and be
something we could follow so so there's
so the obvious thing about this tapestry
of food and kind of you know culinary
carnage that's happening there's a
moment on the couch with with the owner
with that little twig little
Pete the garnish that's really it's it's
it's sort of earned all of a sudden it's
really earned you're having fun and the
puppy so cute and you love puppies and
the expressions are exactly like there
they are or the way you'd want them to
be with the puppy and it's growing and
all the foods and everything but then
all of a sudden you sort of like oh
there's like a there's a connection here
I think it sounds it I'm happy it works
it's the kind of thing where you you
feel like you feel like you're making it
happen and then it's not do you really
get to see it with an audience and sit
in the back and kind of observe the
audience that you know it actually kind
of connected I think you're worse just
that moment the way it's lit you really
believe it but they meet um Christina so
this is a big operation yeah he'll me
about that keeping the sweet beautiful
little moments over time with a lot of
people well you're basically running
around trying to get people to help you
with your film in between the big
features that Disney is doing and
ideally doing it in a way that Patrick
can just keep focusing on the story and
I'm delivering the resources to him at
the exact moment he needs and he never
realizes that there's any challenge in
it it was really easy wasn't it I mean
we start with you know the the main core
team is about six people that spend nine
months on it and then whenever we can
get an animator to help we ask them to
help in between the other big stuff so
it's a little crew that kind of has to
beg and steal a little bit from a favor
and just do one second of that each day
on the next one so he can see what it's
like to make the movie and after over a
year well congratulations with it the
feast is uh it's incredible my daughter
my middle daughter was uh yeah pleased
pleased with the output all of us were
everyone or so okay me and my molten I'm
scared if I'm the pig over here I'm the
mustache dad over there
yeah is this what it's like in in
Scandinavia there's no mustaches not in
the sixties there were no mustaches I
clearly remember there was some kind of
event at school you know some some kind
of event where parents had to show up
and watch you know play or someone like
that and and the parents were arriving
and these two guys stood at the corner
of the school and they pointed up my dad
and he said come off coming there he is
he's coming the guy with the mustache so
yes it's true it was I tell me yo my
society in Norway at the talk process
with me I mean the colors the it's so I
don't know it's like it's like animation
from when I was a little and then
different ideas sort of flip on their
heads I'm thinking in particular of the
like the leaves once the little girls
once the man is left the downstairs man
is left there's and they're in the swing
there these the leaves are really
interesting they're kind of translucent
like green like why that wow that's all
that's a new question oh I tried that
i'm watching it and i'm trying to con
try to growling well any of them not
just to lisa any of the changes that you
yeah i think that the leaves I mean this
is a very this is a story where this
middle sister sort of lays her soul bear
for four of the world and I think it
just made sense that some things are a
transparent that you could kind of see
through things and the stories told over
over summer and in the beginning I say
that it's spring and then it towards the
end I just wanted to have some
indication that the seasons were
changing and so the leaves or not the
leaves because we don't really see
leaves but the colors the colors change
and the color palette really is take
it's pretty much straight out of a
textile finish textile designers called
marimekko they have a whole bunch of
really beautiful colorful patterns and
that's basically the inspiration for the
palette that's what I thought I was
going to
um okay so I have three daughters by the
way and I'm starting to feel I don't
know whether to feel badly about him in
America I sort of feel like the middle
child is the one who's always seen to be
the disadvantaged it's in some way it's
hard has to be the middle child for some
I never understood why but I guess I
wasn't middle child but but in this in
this one the middle child seems to have
it she's one two three you know not the
oldest not the Arias always the middle
but it doesn't seem it's kind of a
neutral emotional load on on the idea of
the middle child tell me how but she's
totally cool with that I mean she's
really you know smart kid this one I
noticed the middle child lives in my
family I mean I remember reading it
something out of Psychology Today a long
time ago that such stop blaming your
parents your siblings your siblings made
you who you are and that's why I have
that one two three yeah because not
because I really believe that the order
really makes a difference but I think
there is a certain kind of competition
for your parents attention and enhance
the numbers that you would usually have
you know and some kind of you know track
and field race or something like that
okay before you go you just have to
explain the molten this uh I look cool
to me I don't know if it's just a boy's
I looking at it shouldn't wasn't
traditional bike but tell me well now it
wasn't them it was like totally you know
totally uncool none there was one other
bike like that in in our town it
belonged to my father's business partner
I think I think at the time my dad just
wanted everything that he had and so we
got that bike but it was it was the
first it was I mean it was a
revolutionary design it's really true
and it was popular in Scandinavia for
about two years immortalized now thank
you for last yeah thanks to you know but
done but I mean it's really the bike
thought that sort of the mini bikes that
came later as a model done so it's uh
you know it's some it's an iconic bike I
like it the last moment the kids choose
like they seem genuinely happy with us
with the skis mm-hmm but they're not
happy with the bike but they're gonna
choose to be happy yeah they choose to
be happy I think they just decided that
you know gratitude you know it's easier
than arguing awesome let's send that
message Arab world all right a single
life urs everybody loves a happy ending
there wasn't any other way it could end
up what happened at what point in your
life did you realize that this
phenomenon might be possible the scope
controlling or semi controlling your own
the the three people who made it but
Malika blow and your van and myself we
were studying at an art school in the
Netherlands and we were listening to a
records and it skips and we thought did
a record skip or did we travel in time a
little bit and that's dead ID stuck for
us for 10 years and I finally we got to
make the film and what's the character's
name a pia pia but I talk to you about
pH breasts
yeah everyone's thinking it I gotta ask
it's it's it became a bit of a special
speciality of me to do the rest on our
characters and with with this one it was
like when it was finished I had a day of
doing breasts which is really a nice day
yeah looks good on a CV man it's all
right but and yeah Wow well how about
one more hand for our animated short
film makers thank you so much have a
great time at the night at the evening
and just know you've created something
beautiful for all time and everyone here
and everyone in the inner world
interwebs will be enjoying it for all
time thank you very much can you play
the piano on my head did you did before
what you need is to just tap your
fingers play something whichever
boys you to dinner today right before
we'll have dinner I we've got news well
and we've got me for you too oh yeah man
gyms are gonna be vegetarians from Niall
except for sausages loop yeah it's a
trusted I'm burgers as well sausages and
burgers I lunch Christmas we don't want
a turkey we wanna was an energy market
under oast I we will not roast you want
a nut ruse for Christmas is that are a
beautiful I don't make turkey down even
I'm we're gonna be chicken farmers one
way to Mitch gr mark you on dinner note
that when there were no top on your go
to ye talk about you tune it oh I
thought mantua how much what underneath
here and use my tiered of course this is
your munguia do ye some
Zee photographer their own loss to a
quadrivalent alpha if a person with
quinta da Mouse voice my father Craig a
ribbon in Afghanistan if in and get
chicken food artisans added okay here's
the finished product for God was poop
this filthy pretend good night the skids
news get this familiar get near okay
thanks Vance good night da
do we start in the other your cloth okay
you say you felt desperate yeah yeah I
did I I but I'm I much cut much Carmen
out what's made you feel calm us down oh
my god can't say you know sometimes when
life gets bad we feel really desperate
and sometimes we do a stupid things we
wouldn't normally do I know I know but I
go like like I can't blow I couldn't go
but not with not without shut have you
taken some pills 10 uh yes yes
let's welcome up the filmmakers Freya
we've got Oded binnen the writer
director and cinematographer and me home
brazos writer director for Boogaloo and
Graham we have Michael Lennox the
directors here for butter lamp for la
langue Abu do yok who way the writer
director and editor and Julian for a the
producer and Parvana karoon hamza v the
writer director and stefan eichenberg
eichenberger producer and for the phone
call Matt Kirby writer director and
James Lucas the writer is everybody
still here hey everybody well there can
be absolutely no mistake why you all are
nominated for Academy Awards
congratulations
the the time goes quickly so I'll try
and jump in a bit of a ride isn't it
alright so for I ah first iya iya iya
alright so this is a movie where all
normal social conventions and the fabric
of civilization are totally destroyed
and a woman decides to agree to hold a
sign and they get in a car with a guy
get rid impulses impulses get you into
trouble yeah just don't live with your
heart you're fine just don't lead with
your heart you should be good um there's
a real life experience that inspired
this sorry there's a fantasy oh go on I
can just say I remember myself in the
airport as a young younger young girl
watching the people arrive and always
fascinated with the strangers with the
possibility of encounters and that
something like this or some kind of
encounter would happen but in real life
it didn't and that's why you have film
I want to pull on that thread but in the
interest of time I want to say the
moment where he's playing piano on her
hand and then on her leg and he's so
lost and it's weird because earlier in
the film I wasn't as aware of the
vehicle but the more into it he got and
the camera kind of comes outside of the
vehicle you get this sense of now you're
sort of broken from them and you just
have to see that they are in this world
together that's separate from what I'm
experiencing with it can you tell me
about that moment I mean it feels like
it's a combination of we call it the sex
scene yeah there's no sex oh I'm not
convinced because you know he says you
know listen if it's sex you're looking
for and she says no no you know that's
not that's not what I was you know you
sort of think well really and then and
then at the end of the film she's one of
my support I have an 18 year old
daughter I you wonder what's lies in the
heart of a woman and why they go this
way or that way and she gets home and
you think if things might have gone
differently would she not be there I
mean what is it all meeting no trying to
explain that would contradict the whole
enigmatic quality of the film so we
believe they're like 10,000 people who
each of their own answer so well I
thought the performances were stunning
absolutely stunning thank you and back
we have to give it to some are you gonna
come son she must stand and be
recognized absolutely you have to stand
up now this is the moment where you have
to stand out
yeah I must say that it was really
exciting watching it tonight with
sorrowing the audience and in this big
screen and this phenomenal quality of I
mean it was like seeing a restored
version of the film we've never seen it
like this so it'll stay like this always
when you go all right boogaloo and
Graham Michael Lennox where's Michael
are you doing so we didn't even talk
about the regional that there's an
international Flair there's not they
usually there's an American film I don't
think there's an American film
represented in the live action short
subject Kadri this year wow that says
that must say something about the nature
of I don't know something the that's
pretty cool so so so are you a
vegetarian no no these boys are so good
where did you find these boys um I found
him in the younger one Riley he's
actually here Riley Riley could stand up
stand up where z there he is right there
yeah he's already like 10 years older
safely and specially today from welcome
congratulations you were absolutely
perfect we find Riley in a kick boxing
club not joking and Belfast I walked in
and I saw this I saw this kid arguing
with his mom Joe in the corner tell her
exactly what he wanted to do and I just
thought that's the kid and then roaches
changed little boy but no no I know I I
sometimes go to the kick boxing club mmm
and that's where I met him and he said
to me I said you want to be in a movie
and he said how many days do I get off
school
that's what i said when i was your age
and they told me i could be in a movie
oh go ahead yeah and the one that's the
story and you know he agreed to do it he
was fantastic well I thought he was
fantastic no he was fantastic absolutely
so natural and honest and and it's a
performance it's a great performance
that he get a minute both and some of
the things they say to their parents
shocking um we all talked about yeah so
the military is sort of absolutely a
character and present the political
dynamics are there and yet somehow
they're not there it's happening kind of
inclusive of that except that there is a
moment where the soldier passes and he's
he's smiling and being sort of
affectionate as the vehicle passes by to
the kids so you're almost disarming any
political antagonism but you're you're
letting the weight of what that was like
for them talk talk talk about that that
moment in I mean just the belle of the
beginning bong Belfast 19 you're like
it's it yeah tell me what your feelings
about how you worked this how that
operated for you in this short film well
the story's a true story about the
writers no childhood where his father
worked in a chicken factory and they'd
bring back Juno two chickens and they
reared them like their own you know over
the summer but basically has been a lot
of fantastic films about the north and
iris two new troubles but sometimes for
me they can be a bit Gino solemn and I
think like which is universal in any
conflict that you know family life went
only we wanted to concentrate on the
madness like ruining the writer he
couldn't be here tonight he grew up and
it was normal to have military dunno
they played around that and we wanted to
concentrate on sort of their moments
behind you know closed closed doors so
that SAT up was like here's iconic bow
fast you know here's guns here's the
military but we wanted to segue and to
something slightly more personal yeah
the father the moment or the father
races out to stop them in the street in
the night when they were going to they
were escaping and yeah there was our
felt disoriented by the by the violence
and the but some
they their relationship that father and
sons relationship felt yeah strengthened
or something I don't know it's wonderful
wonderful and the chickens on the
chickens they live are they are they
yeah they can't any of them yeah I don't
know actually no oh they were there
unfortunately unfortunately they were
killed this is ana mosh this is a
celebration of their life this is a
salad it's a perfect okay ah so moving
on so um tell Ronan that he was he was
missed him and we thought about him and
enjoyed his story very much okay butter
lamp pronounced properly hue how do i
pronounce it the French they don't yeah
it was pretty well it says generate oh
he did yeah they don't put builder yak
sounds pretty good so many things to
think and feel through this one first of
all clearly iphones were not prevalent
at that moment as people who would need
this wonderful American Gothic set up
for you know to preserve their to
preserve their life but I you know
identity and I had all these not words
that could come up but it seems like a
weird juxtaposition of preserving a
history that's being lost with this kind
of absurdist fantasy I don't know tell
me what you're doing good how shall I
feel how should i feel about this
because i felt it was so funny in those
faces are so incredible just to look at
the history in the lives of just right
on their faces and it's fun and it's
funny and the grandmother who's not
being respected but who's sort of
teaching and then she and then the lifts
and you sort of think i feel guilty for
everything I just felt like like I'm
missing like I'm like I didn't like his
history just a whisper or something I
don't know no don't feel guilty it's
gonna be okay
no I wouldn't tell me he wouldn't tell
me stuff you tell me what am I supposed
to feel no I don't know what to say it's
a definite you've gotta by seeing the
film yes there's people people in this
in the frame that we're not used to see
and they're very authentic and and and
there's some kind of a game with this
set up with the backgrounds when we're
not seeing where they are where we are
choosing backgrounds of things that they
they might like that they don't have and
not seeing what they have near near them
those it wasn't hard to get to the place
where you had the perfect frame that you
know you can't see what's going on but
it just it seemed like maybe it took a
lot to get the backdrop framing perfect
the back the background was pretty
pretty big 22 yet to fit in the frame
that was not the hardest actually I have
what was the hardest well the hardest
was to go out there I talked about
because hue as speak French Way want
chinese also but not really good English
so I'm kind of let him jump in tell what
was the hardest what was the biggest
challenge making this incredible film
now the the biggest challenge was to to
to to put all all of us together a
french team a chinese crew Tibetan
nomads and it's obviously to go out
there and and work with them and shoot
them because that the major goal to to
to get that movie work is to get the
real people on the frame and they were
over there there were no nowhere else so
in the story are they are they tourists
you know and no in the story they're
supposed to be living out there so this
is just a gay and the photographer he's
the kind of tourists he comes back from
the city and he
proposed to take picture of him so the
where did the original idea come from
from him why where did they come from
well I think he went there a few times
ago before and he was impressed he met
those people he was impressed of their
way of living and and I think it
questioned himself about identity and
when he came and studying filmmaking in
Paris he he went again on on that idea
on that question and she wanted to make
a movie talking about tradition and
globalization and how how do people
manage that well it came across
beautifully beautifully cinematically
wonderful and performances without words
and and the boy the boy they keep
calling him the kid but the man who
doesn't want to where he doesn't want to
take office mothers like Chet and then
he comes back because he want me what he
wants to be remembered he wants to have
the incredible incredible okay so thank
you for coming so far thank you yeah
parvaneh like I have it I have a
daughter you know I have three daughters
but one is here was 18 and I just keep
looking at her and thinking about her
her journey you know her her becoming a
butterfly and watching partner you know
there's one moment where she looks at
her neck when she's in that department
store and she sees something about
herself and she takes her scarf off and
it feels like maybe a political
statement that's not a political
statement but you can't help but be
aware of what Western thought is about
that moment in a department store and
then she gives the scarf to her friend
in a moment of yeah a life-affirming
gesture tell me about her that tell me
about the actress first tell me about
the performer find her and what was it
like to work with that young girl
well I found the actress both of them in
a casting casting agency before that I
was searching a long time because i was
actually i was searching for a Afghani
actress but I realized that in
Switzerland there aren't so many I mean
there aren't so many actress actors
Afghani actress so then i was i was
searching for iranian actress because of
the same language and in this agency I
just found Nisa and axial she's here oh
my goodness hello congratulations
wonderful um she was one of them some of
the actress that I have seen only on the
in the picture and I invited to refer to
just to see her because I thought she
was I like her face and does not natural
tea in her face and then we had his
casting with the other actress with
Cheryl and when they play together I was
like okay that's that's great moment
when they hold hands to the first time
when they're running away from the the
guy you just think it's a it's a great
friendship that's a great it's a great
built earned friendship I love that
moment so so where they where she going
at the end is she going to Afghanistan
she's going back to work where's she
going you tell me
it's a whole night of that wherever she
was going she was going there with
confidence is what I got out of it and
that they would be together it was it
took it took it lingered that moment of
separation in a train station and I
started thinking when is showing those
shots of the train afterwards that it's
like we really know who we are when
we're in the middle of going from one
place to another so I so I just didn't
know I mean I it's just a thought that
occurred to me these movies provoke
thoughts um is there anything the fact
that she was so the both girls but but
that she was so independent she's
working by herself she's negotiating her
own fee by herself she's eating by
herself she's traveling to send the
money by herself and she's there's a
there's a really powerful loneliness in
the movie was that I don't know I mean I
might be easy to lose that somehow in
the hustle and bustle of making a film
tell me how you what that meant to you
to protect that that feeling of
loneliness for me it was important just
to I mean I had this backstory in my in
my head of how she came to this country
I mean probably she had a real big big
journey behind her and it was also
important to you know to to show them to
audience that's how she how she acted
how she what you do with this with his
long enough with this with his foreign
country and how she can yeah how do you
say behave grow learn yeah how she yeah
well the split the film's figs were but
to me it's um like I keep telling you
RAM I'm a father I've got three
daughters so I watched this and I keep
thinking she's working so hard to send
this money home to her father her sick
father she's working that hard that's
not her money I know she would um it's a
beautiful film thank you for that um
Stefan do you want to say anything about
the about the production about the
actual physical production or anything
yeah if you have a question well it
seemed I mean how long did it take to
fill my me was it done over a period of
time or we did shoot the 10 days and it
was a yeah was a big program program
because yeah we had a lot of different
locations and a lot of yeah really
difficult locations for example the
asylum center that was a real asylum
center so we had to find a science and
very could shoot and where the real
refugees yeah what would play themselves
so it it took a long time to find the
center like that but it was our goal to
shoot in a real center and not to to
imitate one in the cold it looked pretty
cold it was was actually the coldest two
weeks in this year i'm pretty sure you
couldn't meet any any short filmmaker
you meet they oh it's always the coldest
to you know three days like why why is
it that it always has to be the harness
during those minutes that we finally get
to make her our film okay the phone call
Matt Kirby and James Lucas are both here
Manu hello hello
just uh just a heartbreakingly beautiful
love story um that's to thank you I'm a
father of daughters well suited but so
um so she fails right her mission is hot
tub than she oh she was killing my good
was she yeah she tried but I mean if
you're if you're gave it a best shot
yeah so the very same time yeah that's
the point and she saved him too though
she'll hold someone's hand when they're
dying on a battlefield that seems
logical I think it's harder for this
girl was big a distance mm to reach out
say physically tricky that's why they
never get to see the guy cuz this is
makin it you just you know it's jim
broadbent i just give me one look at him
um I didn't I didn't know he'd won an
Oscar when we were filming it and
halfway through someone said you know
pointing the camera here man cause he
won an Oscar hello is he one of and I
did think about it and then I thought
now it would blow it we'd need to stay
in her shoes we need to be on her side
and be like a detective trying to work
things out like she is so and also not
showing his face it allows the viewer to
conjure conjure their own mental imagery
I suppose if who that person is and that
was quite important I think you put your
own grand dad in there that don't you
you kind of well insert Lee I kept think
about my wife and my wife and I've been
together 24 years and I kept you know
it's a beautiful love story I'd like to
think that at the end of our lives we
feel that way for each other and and if
it's been two years apart I know it's a
gorgeous it's a beautiful love story
tell me I can't imagine that anyone who
sees this wouldn't want to ask you how
you did it how'd it was he on the phone
did you record it was it someone how did
you actually do the pet those
performances
they're both on the phone together all
the time we shot for two days so when
she picks up the phone he's there we
filmed in a very cold place as well it's
called London London in the way we were
in an old empty office block so we built
Jim a little room in a kind of an old
toilet thing very popped him in there he
had a big blanket around him and we left
him in there for two days with a
microphone and it still not realizing
that leaves an Oscar winner yeah I think
he might still be led yeah we let him
out he was no he was wanting an Oscar
win or check your local laboratory uh
but did was a rehearsal time before that
but bet we couldn't really get much time
with them so I was a little bit worried
but Sally organs particularly was the
most amazingly prepared actor I've ever
worked with having said that i usually
do burger commercials where people have
to his name mmm and often lake they have
trouble with that or get it wrong but
she she was better prepared than them
and she she could walk on set and do
it's 20 pages of 20 pages of dialogue
she could do the whole thing in one hit
so we were doing long takes weed the
whole thing is maybe five takes and some
of them was there weren't alternative
takes because her and Jim they run they
were on separate lines so we could
record their sound separately and you
know control it but you could hear each
other but they were also being recorded
so yeah yeah so yeah like they're crying
meant that we couldn't use much more
yeah so where did the story come from it
came from masson I'd sitting down and
sort of discussing you know who had sort
of ideas that we were sort of throw
around didn't Liam and that we actually
coincidentally both our mothers were
listeners or you know phone counselors
so that was the impetus i think it was
for them really we made it for them yeah
it's pro mother it's pretty great pretty
great alright well my my wonderful red
light is on in the back of it um I wish
you all a most fun evening in the night
of the Oscars and just thank you on
behalf of everyone else here for
creating such beautiful beautiful
moments for us and telling wonderful
stories in such a beautiful way and how
about a round of applause for our live
action short subject nominees for 2014
thanks very much